I was with great Opie from Opie and
Anthony shale and sherrod had given Opie
edibles in a chocolate bar right and I
didn't I never taken Edel's before I'm
not a drug I don't know Opie just gives
me the chocolate bar I know you supposed
to take half of a half of the square of
the chocolate bar okay so oh and I love
sweets I mean I got hot you know
Michael's 250 up in have sweet tea so I
love sweets you know so I literally oh
we're on the train going to the
Islanders game New York Islanders game
and Opie just gives me the chocolate bar
and just starts looking at his phone so
I didn't know you're supposed to take
half of half of square I ate the entire
chocolate bar just to the head Shiraz
balls need a kid chocolate oh my god
okay
I forget that it even happened because
Opie just forgot me was like not doing
the weed so hoping he just gave me the
talk bar didn't even think about it I
just [ __ ] crush this thing right
having a good time all of a sudden right
the Islanders game first period buzzer
goes off man I thought somebody threw a
spear from the top of the jumbotron
under my right through the right side of
my head cutting off the left side of my
body I pop up a let's see I go I'm
having a stroke I'm having strong so I'm
yelling at I'm having a stroke right I
forgot that I was even on edibles I'm
convinced I'm having a [ __ ] show
yeah so I go up the stairs and I'm just
walking around like I'm having a stroke
Opie I'm having stroke he's like you're
not having stroke I'm like dude I'm
having a [ __ ] stroke I'm at the left
side of my arm it doesn't work and I'm
like flinging my arm and it's not
working so then I'm like I'd have to
throw terrifying dude so I'm in a packed
Islanders game and this is LA to New
York City I'm a big andhe's fan Opie's a
big Islanders fan so people know who we
are of course they know Opie and they're
like so they'll stop at COP they're like
oh that guy is always on the show so
they're talking to me and I'm trying to
have these dude the actual just as luck
would have it the Islanders broadcast
team
interviewed opium brought me on the
interview yeah and I cursed on [ __ ]
SN why would you say I yelled [ __ ] the
Rangers because they're playing rape so
they're like you know camera down see ya
you know so I literally I had gotten
tickets and I had gotten tickets from
the Islanders the ticket Connect was
mine from the island just so they found
out that I yelled [ __ ] the Rangers lose
the tickets I leave
if I leave Barclays Center like walk up
to a police officer who's in full SWAT
riot gear cuz I mean it's New York City
these guys have real jobs to do this
terrorist activity I woke up to him I
said officer I'm gonna be 100% honest
few three with right now
Ivan jested drugs and he goes up he goes
and he goes what do you mean he goes up
I said I said I'm having a stroke he
goes and he goes okay what kind of drugs
did you ingest I said I can't tell you
the type of marijuana strain that I've
been consumed any legal amount of drugs
I was trying to use all these
professional words dude he started
laughing at me
so hard I thought he's gonna shoot his
gun in the because kid get the [ __ ] out
of here and I was like you know so he
doesn't get the [ __ ] out of here so I
get in a cab it's on 4th Avenue and 8th
Street I get in a cab I'm like take me
to where I live 4th Avenue and 93rd
Street so that by the way it was so I it
was freezing was January but I had my
Jaclyn I was so [ __ ] hot I asked his
cab driver to open up all the windows
this guy open up all the with us and he
was like shivering and freezing I was
like guy I'm sorry I'm having fun -
stroke right now I'm on drugs you got to
keep these windows down and he was like
I'm so cold
I'm so cold I was like if you could show
me a value s passport I'll put the
windows up I said they're staying down
literally dude it's 43 the cab drivers
stopped at a light at Fort Devens 63rd
Street I looked out I'm like I'm home I
open the door I open the door and he's
like I thought I was on 93rd XI but the
six and the nine were you know reversed
in my head bro I'm [ __ ] sweating it's
like eight degrees out I throw my jacket
like a $400 North Face jacket in a
public garbage pan in New York City Mac
right in Sunset Park Brooklyn I start
sprinting home I don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening I didn't live with my
kid's mom at the time I go to my kids
mom's house it's 10 o'clock at night I
ring the bell home do it I ring the bell
she goes what are you doing here I was
like I'm having a stroke and she was
like Kris you're not having a stroke I
said I'm having stroke I've ingested
I've ingest it drugs so she goes oh my
god she goes are coming
so she goes you have to take a shower
she knew she used drugs and she was a
kid it's like you have to take a shower
she's like ah all showered I know I know
she goes take a shower love you dad yeah
so I take a shower I take a [ __ ]
yeah I [ __ ] start drinking this milk
and then I take a shower
I take a shower with my shoes and socks
on so that means I got completely butt
naked I put my socks and my shoes back
on I step in her shower I haven't heard
this story I haven't heard like like
like a black eye at this point exactly
exactly yeah I gotta get the grip
totally taking a shower with my [ __ ]
shoes and socks on and then it's like
I'm literally it's getting bad and then
out of nowhere just bang I start
hysterical laughing just hysterical
laughing having the [ __ ] best time
and then it was going back in waves
hysterical laughing terrified hysterical
laughing terrified I slept on the floor
in my at that time 2 year old daughter's
room all true I sleep on the floor with
her her she's got a stuffed animal piggy
she [ __ ] loves its animal
I at some point in the night I take
piggy off her bed sleeping on the floor
I wake up Piggy's mouth on my taint
literally and I was sleeping but naked
on my dark my two-year-old daughter's
bedroom funny but [ __ ] to think about
what she has to wake up to yeah three
years old her father who does live in
the house anymore is naked with her
favorite stuffed animal even her dad's
ass my balls an [ __ ] and then I woke
up you know my kids mom like woke me up
and she saw what was happening cuz she
was the one who woke me up she was like
Chris you get out and then and then like
she sees the whole thing and she's like
this is why we can't be together you
can't do it that's the worst do it
edibles man talk me off I called him in
the middle of nights I ate a brownie
same thing exactly thing I kept pacing
the Roger potent him and they stay for
yeah I thought it was gonna die and I
and they the clock was moving so slowly
I was like what is it was a minute an
hour would go by him one minute with a
foul by and I called Artie I go I called
the poison control center and I go I
think I took too much marijuana and he
said where are you he said how old do I
730 where
where are you and I go I go oh and I
hung up on a house phone back then right
and then I called Artie and I said I
feel like I'm gonna die cuz you're not
gonna die Phil jumping and he talked me
down for 45 minutes dude whoo what
seasoned drug addict do you call you
call your boy come on come up thank God
for Artie cuz what kept me when it comes
we called Joey Diaz knows the edible
[ __ ] I did I got so high in Jamaica with
my girlfriend I got there and I tipped
the guys you have a wine is really good
damn I'm divorced now are you seriously
really yeah dude what are you doing
tonight I mean you want to get some
[ __ ] edibles sooner than I know tell
me you were [ __ ] Devoy whoa whoa
tortellini tush
no you're not my guy I'll [ __ ] cancel
kill me right now Josh friends I'm
saying you're not my type man why don't
we go to Jamaica why do you keep looking
me up and down like that I didn't know
you were [ __ ] stop making this [ __ ]
weird hon oh don't go my hon now it's
sounding start about to make him head
what the [ __ ] do you wanna do you wanna
get a timeshare I don't think so I
didn't know you were single huh I'm
confused
Wow your teeth are straight do it that's
the only thing it's straight about me oh
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]